今日本で例えば投稿ができる。投拒否を
心理学で直す治らんやないか。最初ね
ヨットスクールをやった時にもう何年間か
小学校から始まって中学生になってもまだ
投票をやってるという子供がずっと何年間
か心理学に通っとったんやね。心理
カウンセラーでところがちっとも良くなら
ん。何の変化もない。親はなんかおかしい
んじゃないかということでうちに入れたい
。その頃はうちは子供をしくとこだという
風に乗っとったんやね。で、親としても
死護れにゃダめよと思っとった違いないん
や。で、うちに入れたら1回トレーニング
したら次の日から学校行き始めた。もう
今夜になったんやけどね。これは一体何な
んだということや
。他のね、それの専門家カウンセラーとか
大学のなんとか社会事の体操な名前のとこ
があって、そういうとこに言いに行った
わけよ。うちでこういうことが起こりまし
たと。うちはそんな子供入れたくないんや
。優秀な子供入れたいんだから。オタクも
もし困ったらうちと同じことやったら
うまくいくんじゃないですか。したら
怒り出してね。決まって怒るんや。あの
連中自分ができんからやね。ある時当時
相談所で投稿拒否なんか扱っとったもんで
。そこのおっさんはそんなもん治るの
当たり前やないか言うてそこの東山公園と
いう動物園があるんやがあの池でボート
乗したら治るよ。もうそれはええやないか
。自分とか治らん。どうして乗せないの?
したら治るというのはな、そういうこと
じゃないんだって言うんや。学校行って
ない子が学校行ったから治ったとは言え
ない。どうしたら治ったということになる
んや。明らかに学校に行けなかった子供が
学校に行けるようになったということなん
やから。それでええやないかよ。後の教育
は学校に任しとけやろ。したらそんなこと
やないんだって。一生かかってもやるもん
なんだよ。てあんたね一生かかって治っ
たって手遅れだよ。そうでしょ。有会とか
言うんやね。もうこんな連中が直せるわけ
ないじゃん。まず自分直せよって言たら
なってくるわね。どこ行ってもそういう
態度やって大学でそれを扱っとるところへ
行ったらば何しろうちに来るのは難しい。
本当に難しいのばっかりがうちに来るから
。だからあんたんとこに行ったのは難しく
ないやつなんだっていう。申し訳ないけど
、ちょっと一緒に見せてくださいよって
そのカウンセリングやっとうと一緒に見に
行ったらなんや全然難しくないやつや。一
発引っ張った学校行きそうなやつや。これ
もあかん思ってね。連中は無力ないんだ
からしょうがない
。あれが治ったということが新聞に乗っ
ちまってうわーっと来たんや。あれ見た
だけでもどこも直せんっていうことが
分かったわね。だったらやるかいうことで
ヨットのためにうちに来てくれたやつは
もう気のどやったけどそういうおかしな
やつがいっぱいになってでそのうちにも
これは画宿やらんとダめだ言うて合宿やっ
てで直しってでマスコミが憎んで自分たち
のが作った人間をうちが直すということが
消しからんことや攻撃を始めたんやね。
リベラルのバカどのおかげであれらができ
てリベラルのバカどものおかげであいつら
が治らんのよ。で、一生ダメになるところ
をうちが作ってやったんだ。そのうちを
必死になって潰したいんや。あれおかしい
と思わん?うちは高坂職員住人の株式会社
やね。それを全マスコミが寄ってたかって
。マスコミどころが今日1回も来たけどな
。あれ1匹踏みつすのに像が100匹
集まったようなもんや。おかしいと思わん
か。よっぽど後ろめたいことがあったから
そういうことやったんやね。ともかくうち
の存在はなくさんといかん。
ところがマスコミの記事を読んだ人は
面白がっちまって、あいつは日本一悪い
やつだにしちまったんやね。だからあれ
から50年も経った今頃になってもまだ
文句言ってくるやつがぜ。お前何言っ
とんやって?あれ50年前に言ったことや
ねえか。なんとかかんとかうるさい。どう
のこうの言うて怒るもんで。お前よっぽど
恵まれん男やね。言って50年間うちに
文句ばっかり言い続けてきたか。だけどな
。お前が恵まれんのは俺のせいやないや
ないか。てめが自分が悪いから。どの子の
ものでそういうことはこっちに来て言え。
電話なんかで言うんじゃない。本当に文句
を言いたけり目の前に来て俺の目を見
ながら文句言えしたら何言っとる?そんな
とこ行くのは怖いよとかなんとか言い
そんなんばっかりや。だからああいう教育
の犠牲者が俺んとこにケツを持ち込んで
くるんやな。そういう風にマスコミが放し
ちまってだけどあの時もう54年も前や
ぞっとスクールがなくなれば教育は正常化
するなんて言っとったやないかマスコミが
うちをなくしたらひどなったやないかどう
するんやあれはご法でしたと報道すりゃ
ええやないか
[音楽]